well the nor'easter is already
disrupting travel plans this morning
Amtrak canceled more than 80 trains and
modified some routes along the East
Coast nearly 3,400 flights are canceled
and more than 200 are delayed this has
been the worst March for cancellations
in five years Don Dahler is at Newark
Liberty International Airport in New
Jersey where more than 65 percent of
flights well they're already canceled
Don I'm sure we're going to be expecting
more this morning
you definitely are this really tells
this story all of these dozens of
canceled flights here here at the United
Terminal it's normally bustling this
time of day as you can see it's it's
nearly empty if you live on the East
Coast and you're thinking about
traveling by plane train or automobile
you really need to rethink those plans
with the heavy snow that's expected to
come down crews will undoubtedly have
trouble keeping the planes de-iced
and the runways clear most airlines
preemptively canceled flights to and
from East Coast hubs top US carriers
Delta American Southwest United JetBlue
and alaska airlines are waiving fees to
change trips airlines and airports hope
these proactive measures will help limit
the disruptions and get travelers back
in the air as soon as possible officials
are also warning people to stay off the
roads in fact here in New Jersey all
commercial travel on some major highways
has been banned Gail all right Don thank
you